the Joe Rogan experience everybody has
impostor syndrome
two men when you when you meet famous
people I had a phone call the other day
with Johnny Depp you did me and Johnny
Depp are talking on the phone and I'm
like what is going on in my [ __ ] life
or I'm here having a phone call with
Johnny Depp do I come on the podcast oh
I don't know it's just I just want to
talk to him it was just a cool
conversation really yeah yeah good guy
oh he's a nice guy
I'm a big fan he's a sweetheart of a guy
phenomenal but it's like talking to on
the phone like what is this life you
know and people every even I bet even
Johnny Depp feels like he's full of [ __ ]
everybody feels relative like your fraud
let's go pull the curtain up yeah ah
[ __ ] and when everybody said like you
suck you're a fraud like yeah you're
right everyone's cool man everyone I
guarantee you Daniel day-lewis probably
feels like a fraud sometimes it's
imposter syndrome everyone gets it but
so talking to Johnny Depp you're like
what the [ __ ] is happening like what is
before that was Kanye West yeah that was
weird to to you that wasn't insane to um
I was weird too it was real weird it's
weird I met Paul McCartney once at The
Improv I was like Hello what in the [ __ ]
am i doing staring at you
how are you a real thing how are you
really Paul McCartney crazy
I didn't even stick around and talk to
him just said hi kept moving to thinking
about him why was it skip bran I hope
you can handle it Paul McCartney gets
really bummed out Long's wife what if
like did like the Caitlyn Jenner thing
and heckles you doubt me you know have
you ever talked those guys and asked her
on the podcast anyone said no or you
don't even push it Chappelle is an
interesting one cuz they have talked
about it ya know Mike yeah no Rick
Chappelle [ __ ]
his cousin Dave is uh you know David
said it was like he's like I'll do it
sometimes and go but I don't know you
know and I was like dude I hear you I
don't do anybody else's mail have any
time I would you yeah many time and
second of all I get it man you you say
enough with your comedy and it's like
dave is a smart guy man he figured it
out he figured out where was slipping
away when they were [ __ ] with him
when he was doing the Chappelle show he
was like you know what
just sit back for a bit just sit back
for a bit and they started dude do you
know what he did here what an artist
Dave Chappelle is he wasn't scheduling
shows instead he would bring a speaker
to the park I know in Seattle he'd set
up a [ __ ] speaker and do an impromptu
stand-up show and everybody was like
what is going on and at the time he
could have filled up arenas man crazy I
mean still can for sure you know still
can still does the ones I did with him
were phenomenal we had so much fun but
he decided to take time off he decided
that like let me just sit back and you
know this is such at the level you're at
this step away is probably the hardest
to say knows probably the hardest thing
he's our biggest genius he's our biggest
comedy genius and he might he might be
one of the biggest comedy geniuses ever
oh yeah but he's certainly our biggest
comedy genius of today he understands
comedy like nobody else did you hear
what he said Trevor Noah was on a show
and they asked him about opening for
Dave Chappelle
because chappal bought him on a bunch of
dates and Trevor Noah was like he was
saying he was I mean I'm I'm fairly good
at stand-up I'm not the best but you
know I've been a stamp a while now and
he goes I'm in the green room with Dave
Chappelle and he goes then I'm thinking
why the [ __ ] would he have me open for
like he has all these guys like great
comics what do you mean
so he said that to him he goes hey Dave
I don't know man why the [ __ ] do you
have me at your shows why I'm open for
you he was you know a million better
comics he goes I can find any funny
there's a ton of funny people there's a
ton of funny comics he's but you're
funny and then an interesting so to your
point he's like we can go to dinner like
you're an interesting person and people
care about interesting people so these
guys I can bring out we're gonna murder
but they're not interesting people don't
care you're you can murder and you're
interesting that's why you're here I'd
like to talk to Dave see if that wasn't
actually work wrote yeah I told me it's
cool man Jesus George he just Trevor no
just kids Ed's not he said I'm here
because I'm really smart Donald a giant
[Laughter]
[Applause]